foreign
there was never any
doubt in my mind I'd get there it just
didn't know how that would look
Ed Brockman Brockman an absolute Legend
of a man running a whopping 3 800
kilometers from Perth to Sydney day one
in pouring rain strong headwinds blaring
sun and pain no normal human should cope
with
and I've never been in so much pain I'm
just like wriggling like in terms of
like the Run pain and I'm just like my
eyes are on the back of my head I'm
going this is what am I doing like I am
in the middle of freaking South
Australia and the doctor goes look mate
it is gonna [__] kill you to run but
it was never like I'm gonna quit
where Canada
reached his goal of raising a million
dollars he raised more than that to
combat homelessness the 23 year old
Sparky receiving a rock star reception
was around the final steps
[Applause]
foreign
distinct pleasure of sitting down with
Ned Rockman in this conversation we
cover why he got into running how he
progressed so quickly the motivation
behind his trans Australia Adventure the
many extraordinary obstacles that he
faced and overcame along the way
including a near debilitating injury
suffered early in the campaign we
discussed his post-run PTSD how he's
dealing with sudden kind of overnight
Fame his new role as an inspirational
figure most importantly what we can all
learn from his example when it comes to
human potential and the power we all
have to do amazing things when the mind
and the body and the spirit are totally
dialed in and also this insane story
about his toe becoming maggot infested
40K into the run it's facing down rain
and I thought it must be water in my toe
so I've pulled my socks off and then I'm
like
there's like five maggots in there Ned
is the real deal as they say down under
he's a bloody legend I love getting to
know him a bit and this one is both fun
and inspiring so here we go this is me
and Ned Brockman
I'm super excited to be with you here
today a legend in the flesh I'm on my
sabbatical here in Byron Bay and
typically I don't do any podcasts or any
work I try to avoid everything but come
on man I'm here I gotta get together
with Ned we have to make it up I know
and you drove eight hours from Sydney to
come up here yeah I uh we just
established that you were at flew 15 so
I met at my eight hour drive we're um
we're here now so I'm very excited I
appreciate it man I was just uh so
enthralled and enamored not just by the
sheer uh kind of physical and and mental
feat of you running across Australia but
really
um
you know how you comported yourself
throughout uh that experience and the
manner in which you shared all your
vulnerabilities throughout that um
insane Adventure I'm excited to unpack
it with you and and and I think you know
in thinking about uh you know why I
wanted to do this and what makes you
special as you might suspect I'm on the
receiving end of a lot of messages
alerting me about this person and that
person there's always somebody doing
something crazy okay I can imagine I'm
moving on that now and uh after a while
I sort of become immune to it I'm like
okay that's cool amazing you know hat
off to that person
um but it those those Feats have become
less and less interesting to me unless
there's a compelling story behind it and
you're such a unique character I think I
said to a friend like this guy is not
only supremely authentic he is also like
the most Aussie Aussie in the history of
all Aussies like you're a full-on
character dude I guess I guess the uh
the lingo is is strong in May and the
mullet and the treaty I guess yeah it's
pretty Aussie yeah yeah yeah
um I've had the the honor to talk to a
bunch of guys who've run across the
United States yep
um hello sedibe Robbie Ballinger I did
one with Mike wardian that hasn't come
up yet
um Ricky Gates uh I reached out to all
those guys and I was like I'm gonna be
I'm going to be getting together with
Ned and they're all fired up like they
all followed you and they're all like
massive fans yeah um and I asked them
for uh some questions to ask you which
we'll get to amazing and yeah I actually
like Robbie and um hella I remember a
message would be probably a bit Yeah
Ravi said he talked to your crew
recently I guess yeah and it's just like
you know to have that you know like kind
of it's now almost worldwide there's
people all over all over the country
who's been able to been able to talk to
about their experiences and it's been um
yeah pretty pretty wild yeah uh it's the
best of what social media has to offer
social media has a lot of problems uh
but um a lot more negative than positive
but when you can use it for the good
it's the ability to just inspire people
all over the world without any kind of
filter or middle map absolutely powerful
thing and you were like this amazing
example of that yeah thank you people
all over the world but what clinched it
for me was you know so uh you know I was
like oh this guy's Ned's doing this okay
I'm sort of paying attention from a
distance like that's cool uh but it
wasn't until you rolled into Bandai and
I saw thousands of people there and I
was like what the [__]
how did that how happened because my
friends who've run across the United
States they finish their friends are
there families there it's pretty
uneventful in terms of you know kind of
uh uh you know Mass enthusiasm about
that accomplishment um but in your case
it felt like the entire country was just
holding their breath waiting for you to
finish this thing and the the kind of
reception that you received at the at
the at the finish line was something I'd
never seen like how did that is that
just an Australian thing or like what
was that about I think the Aussie thing
was a part of it but I also think it was
quite a
um I would almost say a it's been a
pretty crappy time for people and kind
of coming out of covert and it's been
like everyone's trying to do more stuff
now and so this it was almost a shining
light in a kind of you know crappy time
and so people were just relying on me to
show up each day and kind of used me as
a fuel for them and yeah by um you know
I was I was showing up and I got quite
injured along the run and and but I was
showing my as you said vulnerability day
in day out whether I was feeling amazing
I'd be screaming at the thing saying I'm
feeling amazing or I'd be crying and and
just showing all the hurt I was feeling
I think people were like oh my God if
this you know powerful person can do
this I can too and I can get behind it
and
um and so yeah the the further and
further I got and the more and more I
showed them about myself and what I was
doing and like the the original goal was
100K a day and which is 60 odd miles 62
miles right
um and I stuck to that stuck through
that for the first 11 12 days and then
got a pretty severe Shin injury and I
kind I went disappeared for one day on
social media I was so present and you
know posting my daily update yeah there
was a gap on the Instagram feed and uh a
couple days there I recognized I reckon
I've got a good 100 messages going mate
are you okay and meanwhile I was 14
hours away from where I marked the pink
line on the road and um getting an
injection and trying to work out a plan
to get back and get running again
um and then yeah the day after I just I
screamed let's [__] go on the screen
and then people just like oh my God he's
back and it just yeah built this
momentum which was just
um gives me goosebumps thinking about
Bondi like that those scenes there and
coming down and I wish I could relive it
but it was such it was over in a Flash
right yeah
um I've spent a lot of time thinking
about the power of of inspiration and
the difference the qualitative
difference between uh aspiration and
inspiration so I know like David Goggins
is like a North star for you he's
somebody who's unbelievably uh you know
powerful in his ability to motivate
people and and be this
um
you know kind of Beacon of of of
inspiration but there's something
inaccessible about him because he's so
extreme right yeah and he's so taciturn
and and so I think
it's a challenge for somebody to kind of
emotionally relate to his interior
experience because it's so you know on
the far end of that Spectrum whereas you
fall more into this you know kind of in
the middle between aspiration and
inspiration because people can see
themselves in you because of that
willingness on your part to be
vulnerable to show the warts and to talk
about how much you're hurting and how
much you hate it like how it sucks and
like all of that absolutely even like
like for me Goggins was uh not it still
is a big form of inspiration for me
um and it kind of kicked my mindset into
gear like kind of kicked me into a oh
you can actually tap into that and start
doing more you know with your day and
start running more and start you know
doing uncomfortable things and then I
was exactly that I found that it's not
all about staying hard all the time like
I tried to emulate that a bit but it
just you'll burn out like there is no I
just don't know how
it's possible to continue to be like
that because if you do something for
example run across the country and you
know averaging 80k a day or 85 Plus you
are going to crash at the end of that
yeah it's not going to go smooth no and
you're like your adrenal fatigue your
mental state and that you know you have
to keep showing up and you have to keep
getting
in that mindset of fight or flight every
day so when you do get out of that it's
like your body's going oh he's resting
now let's chill out and if you keep
trying to fight that it's just gonna
it's gonna end badly right so I think
there's Beauty in
getting really uncomfortable and showing
up when it's the time to but when it is
the time tonight it's like allow
yourself to relax and and appreciate
what your body's done for you because
you know you've only got one of them
you've only got one set of legs it's
like you've got to uh you know allow it
to be be settled settle down yeah uh
we're gonna go through all of it but I
want to start with uh like how you're
doing now because in the post-mortem how
many months has it been now like three
months right like so how is the body
doing how are you doing physically and
how are you doing emotionally like what
has this you know couple months been
like for you yeah it's been it's been
interesting and it's like I don't really
know how you navigate these things
unless you do a lot of them right um
my physically I'm actually pretty good
now
um I've got still got like you know fat
pad and my feet issues because I was
running on just tar no dirt no grass
um and then I've got like I had a few
hip wear and tear like glued made
tendons but other than that I'm pretty
pretty
Jordan to be honest I've been running
um
and strength training in the gym
stretching doing all the stuff
emotionally and like
um you know spiritually I'm like
exhausted I'm still not waking up like I
usually in the in the go time I'm a 4am
wake up go go you know I'm there's no
stopping but now I'm like it's like 6
a.m and I'm like open my eyes I'm like
what's going on here
um Sun's up so that's usually a bit hard
for me when I see the Sun up when I'm
usually used to getting up before it and
go getting it
um but I'm I'm getting there it's like I
had a rough I had a rough probably
month in the Middle where I
almost a lack of purpose so you've you
know I've had this idea of this two-year
goal got the goal woke up every day
thinking about it went to sleep thinking
about every night and then
to be finished and then to you know have
nothing almost to push for it's not that
I don't have any other goals or any
other you know happiness in my life it's
just that when you're so devoted to
something it's really hard to you know
oh amazing now let's get on with the
next thing it's like I've gotta you know
be okay with sitting back and trying to
ponder what I've just done and and
appreciate it you know
um so yeah I had a tough home for four
weeks or so where I just
found myself a bit lost
um but yeah I guess I've I think that's
probably the lack of exercise too to be
perfectly honest when you're moving for
17 hours a day you need to uh uh you
know you go cold turkey on it you're not
going to be able to feel that same
excitement so uh but yeah I'm actually
I'm pretty happy with where I'm at at
the moment and I've just got to
appreciate that my body has done a lot
for me
but you did you have talked about PTSD
like night terrors the alarm would go
off and send you into a panic thinking I
could get up and run 100. and like the
kind of you know the emotional residue
of of like enduring that trauma and
having such an intense experience yeah
absolutely and the PTSD I think that
started probably 10 days into the run to
be honest because I'm like Australia
it's I don't know about America I know
it's pretty there's a lot of people in
America but it's pretty similar distance
running across as running across
Australia or probably a thousand K
actually yeah it's well 4000k versus
like 3 100 miles okay so five in a bit
it's okay it's in the range so it's it's
yeah so for me it's like when you get
out of wa so Western Australia
um after about 400k it's pretty remote
so you go from civilization and people
to maybe a town every 200 kilometers and
then in the middle of it there's nothing
for like 800 kilometers yeah that's
annoying [__] yeah and so when you get
to
um so you go you head east you go down
and then you literally at um it's called
Norseman
you head across and you don't see really
any people until you hit New South Wales
to be perfectly honest
um and so that's scary and knowing that
you've had you've got 900 kilometers in
your legs you've got a good 11 day stint
of running 100 kilometers a day with no
Health Care not really any access to
good food
um you know you're very isolated no
service so you can't reach out to many
people if you know it does go wrong
um so that gets you incredibly uh on
edge and so the fact that it was feeling
like I was
almost going to war like okay this is it
we're going this is yeah we're out in
the depths of hell here
um so yeah I think I knowing I had to
put my head and body through that
when I would go to sleep overnight in
one of these roadhouses which is all
that they have in these towns is just
like a place to sleep
um I mean what are those like bunk
houses or something are they like most
they're just like fuel stations with a
few beds in them
um and the food is like your Pub grub
steak or chicken schnitzel or yeah
you're not getting like it'd be tough to
be a vegan out there I'll tell you that
little vegan Pad Thai yeah definitely
not
um and so for me I'm like well and even
like a chicken schnitzel chips and
veggies It's like got all the oils and
all this it's like not the greatest
nutrition but for me I was just craving
these whatever I could get there I would
eat you know
um and so overnight on the Night On The
Run I would be waking up in the middle
going who's taking me back so I would
have these like out of body feelings and
be waking up going oh [__] I'm 300
meters 300 kilometers back from where I
was so I'd wake up in this Terror of oh
no I've got I run an extra 300
kilometers on top like someone's taking
me back in the middle of the night
um but yeah so a culmination of all that
and when I did finish I was
because there's so many road trains as
well like you know 50 meters long 120
plus tons of that wind when it's coming
at you is like yeah road trains are just
to their 18 wheelers the big the trucks
the cargo trucks yeah the 18 wheeler is
one Carriage so there's like four
carriages oh wow yeah they're like
Australia's pretty well run off trucks
um where they're just going every three
minutes probably across the country so
that road I run is really only for
trucks to be honest
um and so they they would just go every
three minutes so I would even if I had
music they'd just be this like wrong
well wrong I'll pass you every time and
so when it when you're in that mode it's
like
it's just you can't control it but you
still like there's nothing you can do
about it and there's no shoulder really
right absolutely not and any if I was to
run on the like Rocky dirt on the side
it'd be on a tilt of 30 degrees which
meant you know my body's out of the line
yeah yeah
um so yeah definitely no shoulder the
shoulder was all of a foot and so I'm
getting brushed and I'm you know some
trucks were pretty good to me but a lot
were like get off the [__] road mate
um and so yeah I just when I finished
the run I was probably for the first
week out I'd wake up just like screaming
just going like dodging trucks in my
sleep and you know like going oh no I'm
back on the road
um and so yeah that that hurt a bit but
I got on top of that and I'm not still
thinking about trucks at night yeah
that's good and what about the brand
like I I've spent time with uh the iron
Cowboy James Lawrence yeah massive
inspiration of mine too yeah I was I was
uh I was there for the the final day of
his 100 you know consecutive Iron Mans
and how is he going hey he's he's you
know he he's been pretty transparent
about how difficult the recovery has
been and the brain fog and you know his
inability
he's probably I'm sure he's fine now or
at least mostly fine
um but you know he was concerned that
his body might not ever recover his
brain was having difficulty I know you
talked about some brain fog stuff I mean
you know sort of healing the shin and
all that other stuff is one thing but
you know your cognition and just the
emotional like you know waking like you
talked about like spitting all the time
because you're used to doing that you
couldn't stop spitting not and that
would work again I woke up in the middle
of my after the run spot at the wall and
my girlfriend was like you can't go that
much it was it was like it was true
because you're getting the the red dust
yeah and I even I even had like my
airpods in all the time right and so I
must have been pushing dust in there and
when I went on a bit of a holiday when I
finished I couldn't hear out of this
Lefty here and I'm going what's going on
but I got an air check it was just so
much build up of red dots right and I
was like oh this is not good have you
had like blood tests done and stuff like
that aftermath I was low iron
um and like a few other things I was
still inflamed internally so potentially
a gluten problem but yeah
um it was it's all sorted which is good
um and but yeah back like on the on the
trance like on the with the same as iron
Cowboy it's like when I finish the run
you know I'm doing all these media
you know yes media all these podcasts
all this stuff and I actually limited it
as much as I possibly could but when I'm
in them I'm
talking like I'm there but I'm also
talking like I'm out of it so I'm in
this confusion between the two and so
when I get prompted a question I would
be like oh God I'm you know this is
really hard for me to talk about and it
might be either trauma or the fact that
I am still trying to process it so I was
finding that really really hard and so a
few of these chats I'd have I'd just go
blank and then I'd be like oh my God I'm
so sorry guys I actually like I think
this is like my brain trying to block
out what I've just been through right
um but now I'm it's cool because I'm you
know I'm starting to do a few Keynotes
and get the words you know try and
actually work out what I was feeling and
and it's yeah it's pretty um insightful
I guess have you do you have a therapist
that you're working this stuff through
with or um I haven't I haven't yet yeah
I've had them in place but I there is
obviously clearly benefit in having a
therapists but for me I wanted to try
and see how I'd go manage it myself
um but yeah I guess there's I you know
giving me talk that it would be good to
get tools to be able to deal with it
much easier than having to you know find
my find the way myself
so you just turned 24 right Justin yeah
so you were 23 when you did this
incredibly young uh most big Ultra
endurance Feats are are people that are
in there you know at least like their
mid to late 30s if not 40s and into the
even their early 50s it's like uh you
know it's like a sport that a lot of
athletes get into later in life when
they've got a lot of K's under the belt
absolutely yeah so it's very yeah it's
very unusual for somebody so young I
think it's it's cool like the ultra
world is exploding and more and more
young people are getting into it earlier
than traditionally it has been the case
um but you know the added kind of flavor
here is that you'd only been running two
years right you didn't get into running
until you were like 21. yeah literally I
am yeah I just honestly was
about to have a shower I'd looked into
the mirror and I saw back fat and I went
I'm gonna start running lose some weight
and that was that was when I was just
started just turned 21. so you grew up
you grew up on like a farm right like
not like sort of how far like not in not
anywhere near Sydney no no we're at 600
kilometers so west of Sydney pretty well
bang smack in the middle of New South
Wales
um yeah we're 60k from town so the
nearest town to healthcare for whatever
was 60 kilometers away
um that's yeah obviously people would
have thought I might have run into town
assuming my running really but no I
didn't
um yeah we we I mean I always we always
um did sport like rugby and uh swimming
but it was never it was all our parents
choice not us I would have loved to have
not but then I found a love for sport
probably through going to high school
and then just fell out of love with it
when I finished high school and I you
know do whatever 20 21 year old would do
and went out partying went out drinking
um you know skipped exercise and yeah
and then I saw a bit of back fat and
thought I had to get on with it yeah
yeah so you you moved to Sydney uh to
become an electrician yeah right so
you're doing your apprenticeship uh you
know lifestyle caught up to you a little
bit yep on the early side though you're
lucky man yeah people don't have that
kind of epiphany into their life
absolutely it's probably 40. that's
probably the distinct correlation
between Ultron is starting at 40. uh-huh
because it just just had a bit
in early mid-life crisis a young life
crisis that's right right absolutely so
so where does the uh impulse uh so you
so you have this realization like you
know I don't like the back fat or
whatever so where's the leaped uh
putting on the running shoes come from
just that's literally and then when um
and ran and when I knew that I'd you
know energy out energy um food in I knew
that you eat a bit more eat a bit less
and run a bit more you'll burn burn the
fat I have a pretty good basic knowledge
of you know strength training and all
this stuff through sport
um but I just went I've got to get out
and so I actually started doing it
literally for weight loss but when I
quickly realized what the feeling I was
getting of this of running kilometers I
was like oh wow so then I just literally
went okay I ran 5K ran 10K the next time
around 15K and then literally about two
weeks later I was running 21k never run
up over six kilometers before rather
than the you know School cross country
uh and then all of a sudden I'm running
half marathon and I went around 30k and
then I estimated to do you want to go
run a marathon today and it just went
and ran a marathon so it was just like
this oh and then I heard people would
you know run marathons and I never even
thought of it like that was a wild thing
for me
um so this is all in a matter of like
six months and then uh I'd heard of
Ultras I heard people would run 60 80
100 kilometers and I'm like this is this
is pretty cool I'll see if I can do it
and then yeah within within a year I had
finished a 100K run
um and 50 marathons in 50 days
the 50 marathons in 50 days was still
within one year of you because running
yes yeah and and like the 100K and those
other you know running the marathon
those weren't races you you just I just
got you just got up in the morning I was
like I'm gonna do this yeah I actually
got 100 random pumps I actually
literally got home from work and went on
Grotto so I'd do a eight ten hour day at
work get home try and nap couldn't nap
because I'm so excited about the thought
of running 100 kilometers
um put my pack on all I had was a muffin
a banana and two of the water bottles
and then I came back with the two water
bottles empty I didn't fill them up I
just literally had no idea about
nutrition or hydration or electrolytes
um got there got 50K by uh two o'clock
in the morning
turned around ran home found like found
a way I didn't obviously know where any
water was right but you could like stop
at gas stations Like Water for me I was
I didn't even touch the water till I was
at 30k because I was trying to trying to
keep it to you know use it for later
um and then I literally had a muffin and
a banana that was all my nutrition and
you know I know how many people you know
it's gels and Cliff Bars right
everything and I was just I guess I was
like oh cool I've now run 100k with
minimal nutrition like I can look at
what else can I do yeah just kind of
like a light bulb moment yeah I got I
got something in my tank I was just
hungry I was just hungry to see what I
actually could do it wasn't like you
know find your possibility it was like
I'm not actually sure where I can where
this stops so let's go find it and then
yeah I remember running the 100K and
being in that like immense pain but like
you know that awesome feeling when you
finish laying in bed looking up at the
roof going I'm going to do something the
next day I posted a thing on Instagram
saying I'm gonna run 50 miles in 50 days
in a month's time and then I'd never
back to back any runs like that and I
did a half marathon and a half marathon
like 21 21
um like two days later but back to back
and went I'll be sweet and then yeah and
so I am on August no September the 1st I
did August the 1st I posted that and
then September the 1st I was working
full time while I was running the
marathons
um and yeah I'd finished work about 3 30
put the shoes on at four run out the
door and run for four and a half hours
and get home and go again wow yeah
um
there's something really powerful about
the naivete of the whole thing yeah I
think a lot of people get up in their
heads
and they have an aspiration I'm going to
run a marathon or I'm going to do a 50k
or or even outside of running some other
challenge but then they sort of get
lured into this analysis paralysis like
oh I got a 10 percent like I gotta work
out the logistics and then the date for
the start date get keeps getting pushed
back out of fear or whatever but the
impulse to just like be like I don't
know what I'm doing but I'm gonna do it
anyway I have that confidence to do it I
like the fact that you just ran a palm
beat you like there's a lot of instances
in your story where you're just out over
your skis absolutely absolutely like
like when you started the run across
Australia like I've heard you talk about
like not knowing that there was all
kinds of elevation in Western Australia
right like you didn't even get a topo
map and figure out like on what you were
dealing with I knew there was about 20.
people would have that like fully mapped
out I had the room that's all I have
yeah
um yeah I I guess I I saw there was 20
000 is elevation of the whole country
and I went it must be in New South Wales
so I can all be fine by then to run
elevation and yeah it was obviously not
it was always there was a lot in wa yeah
um probably about 8 000 meters elevation
on the first 12 days
but yeah it's it's just like I think
people as you said people just overthink
it and
get so stuck on the fact you know
there's all this scientific research
that you've got to incrementally load by
10 each week if you want to start
instead of otherwise you'll get a stress
fracture you'll get this or that and I'm
going I'm young bones are strong
you know yeah I'm good I'll be right and
if I'm not I'm not and more times than
not I'll find that actually was okay and
I think you know as soon as you have
that mindset of like oh you know
something could go wrong the first
moment of anything slightly off the
track of what you planned will be gone
you'll be done yeah and you know it it's
not without its perils though like we're
gonna get to day 11. yeah yeah and what
happened there so you know maybe a
little a little bit of wisdom and and
preparation might have avoided that yeah
who knows but I guess my preparation is
more mental at this like
still
um I don't I obviously like I Strength
train a lot I do a lot of strength
training my K's I like to be probably
underprepared in kilometers but over
prepared in strength training
um but when you put out what you're
doing and you've put it out there you've
got on you know today show live
television and said I'm running across
the country in September you kind of
can't yeah get it pulled out of it
um and that's a powerful accountability
absolutely and I I love the whole nation
yeah absolutely and they're while
they're eating their weet-bix
um and I yeah I once you put it out
there you can't you can't stop but I had
I had three MRIs on my TBR
um from April till September September
was the start and I had three MRIs
um for to stress for stress fracture in
my TBR because I was just so aware of it
and so my kilometers were like all of 40
plus k a week yeah well a couple
thoughts on that I mean first of all you
can't
there's limits to how much you can train
to prepare for running across the
country right so it's more important
like to your point of of making sure
that your strength training is on point
uh and and being fresh when you start
like you can't show up tired because
you've been you know cranking out so
much volume yeah right and the iron
Cowboy talks about this like when he he
barely did any running before the 100
yeah uh uh Iron Man's because he just
figured he would walk and run his way
into that Fitness and too much running
ahead of time would set him up for
injury absolutely I think if you're
running you know if you're to run 700
kilometers a week
like the time it would take you to be
able to run 500 kilometers a week
consistently would be so long like you
know you it's just so much time on your
feet throughout your training like you
just can't do that yeah but getting your
head around it and getting your strength
and your you know timer on your feet you
you it's just a it's a mind game now
yeah so walk me through the the kind of
uh mental this the decision once you did
the 50 marathons in 50 days I'm sure
that was a huge accomplishment and made
you feel like you were capable of even
greater things definitely um it's a leap
to say okay now I'm gonna not only run
across Australia but I'm gonna break the
record which was 42.43 43 43 and a half
I think yeah yeah so so how did you land
on that
um so it was actually Midway through the
50 marathons when I got to day 10 I was
like I'm gonna do this no worries what's
next I want to have that in my head
because you know I was saying you know
when I you feel a bit lost after it you
want to kind of have what you want and
so
I
um sorry I started yeah I was running
and I did the run and I met up with a
mate after
um I finished the marathons and we're
sitting in in the pub having a schnitzel
and he's like I told him my plan of
running it running 60k a day but because
again it's well the Guinness record was
like 67 and he goes why don't I'm sure
there's people have done it quicker I
went all right I don't know how to look
and I saw that it was 43 and I go what's
that average out to be and it's like it
was uh I think it was 93k a day or
something to beat it and I went 100K
that'd be pretty cool and then I looked
up the guys you know people in America
running across America and Pete castalni
he's you know around 114k a day or
something I'm like why can't I do that
and so you know someone's done something
why what what is limiting me from not
being able to do that why is it that
someone can you know what I mean like
that mental block isn't there for me but
where does that come from
is that instilled in you by your parents
like that level of confidence and
capability I think so I think it comes
from them allowing them
Arkham belief in allowing in doing
something comes from belief in you to do
whatever you want so buy it as long as
you're
allowed and you allow yourself to be
okay with getting whatever it is I think
that is the crucial part so not having
your
um not basing your
the idea of achieving a goal as your of
who you are but achieving whatever you
want with who you are so like when you
if you don't get the record then
it doesn't matter but if you do if you
don't get the record and you haven't
been okay with who you are you're going
to probably align your self-worth with
this record so you're you know not
worthy of getting it for me I'm just
okay with who I am so whether I go out
on a limb and I've you know failed but
I've still tried I have no issue with
that so
by being like my parents have always
been like just whatever it is do it but
do it with absolute conviction don't you
know sit back do it half ass and I was
always like right when I wrote at school
I was always you know I was never in the
top boat but I was always like
I'm gonna get this top boat I was never
in the first 15 but I was like I want to
get in this football team like so badly
so I'd Rock up to training earlier I'd
run to training or I'd just or just a
combination of things and I think
watching dad as well
on the farm like has never complained
this whole life and he's you know rocked
up to work every single day for 40 plus
years and so but not not just
um talking about it but actually seeing
him do it that was kind of a big thing
for me so I guess
another thing I went back to the farm
and saw him actually just show up again
again I'm like this bloke is the biggest
Workhorse I've ever met like and to see
how hard he has worked that for me was
like oh you can actually just keep doing
this yeah I guess yeah I just it came
about by that I guess yeah and and your
parents were part of your crew yeah yeah
it was pretty what was their response
when you told them and you wanted to do
this
mom was all for her she was like
whatever you if that's what you want to
do I'm supportive of you but just
don't have asked it don't you know don't
get all these sponsors and then get
halfway through and go off I don't know
if I can do this so
um but yeah A Mother's Love is you know
her sitting back and watching me put
myself through that was a lot
um and I can tell you every day she
would have been going [__] I want to
tell him to stop but if I do it's gonna
[__] him off because he's you know the
plan was 100K a day this is what we're
doing yeah
um but to have them there for the whole
thing for 47 days like you know you
leave school you leave you know your
parents
they're you know you're going you
probably understand for Christmas or New
Year's or you know your birthday
potentially and but to spend 47 days
with them on the road you know so intent
intensely it was um a life memory all
you know what I'll forget
so you make this announcement you're
preparing uh you're starting to talk
about uh the challenge with the media
and I know that you went on on Mark
boris's show and and and he asked you
like how are you feeling and you're like
oh great you know I'm ready to go I'm
feeling perfect yeah quietly though
you're fully injured your knees are
[__] up uh your trainer uh wrote a
whole blog post about all your injuries
and like everything that was doing about
that behind the scenes yeah I read it
behind the scenes before we're not even
at the start line yeah and you were you
were fully tweaked yep
yeah my so I did it
um prior to announcing this run I'd run
100K since November 2020.
and
uh I was like well I need to remember
how running 100K feels right and in my I
went and did like a bit of a hell week I
went and trained out at
um my family farm for like uh a whole
month sorry I went out and I did two
100ks in a week plus probably
um you know another 65k on top of it and
after the first 100K I did I went pretty
quick and I felt good you know the food
right
and I finished and I woke up the next
morning and my knees I've I've never
been in so much pain
and I'm like this is not good
um and I ran I ran I think 12K the next
day just to kind of you know try and run
on very sore legs but I they were just
I've as obviously pretty uh Patilla like
uh patellar femoral pain right and but
it was just like I had to keep running
on it so I was just like just damaging
it more damaging it more
um obviously just tight quads tight
everything and it was just referring to
my knees and then I had to run 100K on
the Saturday and because I had just said
this is what I have to do I have to run
two 100k's this week it's just a
no-brainer you have to do it and
so I just thought I went this is it's
gonna have to find a way like if it's
not a bone I'm fine like if it's not a
stress fracture we're all good
um and it wasn't so I just had to had to
show up and yeah so when I finished that
I didn't really run until the start of
the till the start of the event yeah
um yeah which wasn't great I'm not gonna
lie
they're kind of like youthful uh I'll be
right arrogance is the wrong word but
like stubbornness yeah stubbornness oh
the wise thing is you know just make
sure when you line up on day one like
you're fully 100 like rested no injuries
none of that but I remember the two days
you could have pushed it like let me
just push the start date yeah but I the
problem is Australia's just so freaking
hot especially in the middle of the
country if I win another month yeah I'd
be oh I'd be a I'd be blistered up on
the back of the back of my legs and arms
um and it just would have been too hard
like it would have been just like the
heat would have just been so intense
that it would have just factored in so
much more like time yeah
um
but yeah I got to two days before
leaving and I went for a run with my
girlfriend and I was just complaining
about my knees the whole time I'm going
this is going to be pretty like I guess
I was only complaining though because I
knew about the pain I was about to put
myself in it wasn't that oh my knees are
hurting it was like
oh [__] my knees are hurting
I'm gonna do some serious damage here
that's all it was going on in my head it
wasn't like oh I'm gonna be able to find
a way to pull out because I couldn't I
had it like I just don't pull out and
how far in advance of the the beginning
this is about two weeks wow so I flew
over like a week or a week and a bit to
go
um but two days before I flew over from
Sydney I yeah I was like telling my
girlfriend that
this is gonna be fun yeah I'm like
potentially looking at walking for 20
hours a day
um to get 100K out and no breaks you
know what I mean it was I was it was
just finding a way um and then yeah I
flew over I ran once when I was over in
wa
um
and like a lot of people think I just
you know I was running because I turned
my Strava off because I wasn't running
in these caves but I was just like yeah
100 plus all good running all these K's
um and I got over there and I'm like
oh no hold on anyway and I just want to
debating it because all I was doing was
thinking about it and thinking about it
and thinking about it and then when I
finally got to
the day one of that morning I was just
so happy because I now I'm in it yeah
um where do you where do you
compartmentalize that that doubt
because that doesn't have any room no it
doesn't and I I there was just no it was
all affirmations of you're gonna do this
there was no like oh no oh no it was
like I was I was thinking about the I
just want to start but I wasn't thinking
about once I was in it I was like I
can't wait for the knee pain because
it's gonna be there I knew it was going
to be there right uh
but it was all just like positive words
it was like I'm gonna get to Bondi you
know I'm either gonna get sent out of
here in a body bag I'm gonna get to
Bondi yeah there was no other way and so
each day there might have been a few
like [__] I'm not like this is [__]
but it was never like I'm gonna quit
there was never any
doubt in my mind I'd get there it just
didn't know how that would look so you
kick things off you pull to get first of
all you pull together a bunch of
sponsors you got Puma you got like you
got a camper van right yeah so you were
able to like string this together
because financially like it's a it's
absolute thing especially when you bring
yeah five or six people there as well
the whole time uh and you get to the
starting line you kick things off it's
all it's all [__] rainbows and you're
sharing positivity on social media a
little bit of like whoa didn't see all
this elevation coming it's beating you
up a little bit so let's get to day 10
11 and like walk me through like that
whole Insanity yeah uh so well like
starting my first day was like it was
really good to be like okay cool 103k
amazing I was done by 5 30 that night I
still had a lot of light in the ice bath
and I was like right we're in this
however I wake up I'm gonna wake up
earlier and get the date on because I
knew the adapting would come at some
point but I didn't know when
I go to day three and that was pretty
well where I was like my worst in terms
of Dom's like just muscular saunas and
then about day five and six my core temp
was just shot so I just could not
regulate my system yeah and so as soon
as I'd finish I'd be freezing my ass off
and then I'd be trying to warm up trying
to warm up
are you getting massages and I was just
shaking I couldn't stop and then I get
in the campervan bed and just sweat
sweat all night and the walls would be
dripping with my Heat swim and so I
couldn't just couldn't sleep so that
first week I wouldn't have slept more
than an hour a night because I was just
so out of whack
I got to
day nine we've just hit that Norseman
section where there's no nothing I've
just camped on the side of the road on
the day 10.
my physio leaves
by just in time just in time and I've
woken up the next day on day 11.
and I got to so I got 42k and my shin my
right shin just was like just so much
swelling I was just like
okay this isn't good this might feel
this feels a bit bone stressy because
I've had a few before and I was like
this feels an awful lot like bone this
is not good
um then we're running my fingers down at
it and it was not didn't feel I was on
the bone but there was just so much
swelling so I was kind of I couldn't
really work it out
I've got the 100K out took me a long
time I was finished at nine o'clock that
night and woke up the next day could not
run for life of me I think I tried close
to 40 times to get in a bit of a rhythm
with running but I couldn't it was just
jarring
um and I've caught my physio but it's
like crackly on the line and he's like
mate oh can you try strap it this way
can you put this in it can you do this
and we try to do everything Voltaren all
day nothing would work
and so I walked 40K that day and I went
look I've got to give myself the best
chance of you know healing so I went a
fish at one o'clock in the afternoon
went to the Roadhouse iced and just
slept just tried to get some sleep back
so I knew the lack of sleep was really
[__] with me as well I was starting
to get a bit Delirious my body isn't
actually recovering
um the best it could and so I gave
myself
um one until three a.m the next morning
so 14 hours
which was much more than I was getting
before I was getting all of six seven
hours
um and then I went again I couldn't do
it and so my physio was rung up
the nearest MRI place which is 14 hours
away 14 hour drive 14 hour drive so
about yeah
nowhere yeah middle of [__] you know it
would have been longer to go back to
Perth
and so I got to 40K and my physio ran
out the sports stop and Sports Talk had
ordered an urgent MRI for the next
morning at this place
and so we stayed the night so June I
drove another four hours to this place
to get the MRI
got the MRI at 12 o'clock that lunch
midday
on the
14th day so the 14th of September
and then
we got the results back I'm in the car
sitting and there goes good news is your
bones are as strong as I've ever seen
for someone being 14 days into this
monstrosity however you've got
suryutanocyanovitis and that's not great
and we're going okay what does that mean
he goes look usually it's a six-week in
the boot do nothing
um but you're not going to do nothing so
we're going to work out what you're
going to do Shin it's just injury to the
shin so sheath yeah so the tendon sheath
has just become so inflamed
um but it can actually get infected
because of the inflammation and so the
further you know the longer you delay it
and so
I've got there what am I doing he goes
look we can cortisone it but usually
you'd have to take five to seven days
off but I know I can do that so we'll
Cortisone and we'll just try and blast
it like try and just disperse it
everywhere and if you can find a dick
disband which is for people with drop
foot it allows it's a rubber band goes
through your laces allows your foot to
pick up and down
um if you can find one of those that'd
be ideal and so we're so my girlfriend's
on the mission to find a dictus band I'm
in the injection part of the hospital
and I'm getting injected into my shin
no anesthetic just straight cortisone in
and I've never been in so much pain I'm
just like wriggling like in terms of
like the Run pain and the shin injection
pain
and I'm just like my eyes are on the
back of my head I'm going this is what
am I doing like I am in the middle of
freaking South Australia getting
injected in my shin after 1500 yeah
you're only like 20 in literally and so
that was a big like and also the the
record slowly getting sure dragged away
was also wearing on my head
and so I got this injection it's three
o'clock in the afternoon and I'm adamant
I'm
running on the 15th morning
we're 15 hours away mm-hmm
I get the injection and the doctor goes
look mate it is gonna [__] kill you
to run but this dick disband is going to
allow you to lift your foot up because
you have no function of it
um but you're just gonna have to work it
out because it's not bone so you'll be
right and I went done got in the car at
3 30 drove 15 hours back to where you
left off
um but thankfully the time zone
was would go back so we got we actually
made up some time not like actually but
in terms of the time we started got
there at 2am
slept we'll lay down for two hours
started running at five got 700k out
there next week
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
you know I've got this injury right the
record's gone this is the point I was
saying before is like if you if I based
my Worth or my you know who I am on me
getting this record then I'd be on a
plane the nearest plane back to Bondi as
soon as I could but for me I was like
what you're doing is so much more
important than any record any putting a
flag in the ground could ever be it was
like you know you you caught on to it so
people were catching on and saying this
right this person just continuing to
show up continuing to like keep fighting
and so when
you know I I had that option to go oh
this is you know it's incredible you've
done 1500 kilometers
um no one would excuse you for not
everyone would excuse you for um
get going home and you'd be
congratulations but I went this is not
what I set out to do I set out to get
from A to B and raised a [__] ton of
money for a charity and I'm not stopping
now yeah well let's get into that I mean
you've spoken uh you know quite a bit
about how you're in intrinsically
motivated person yep uh that motivation
meaning it's coming from within yourself
yeah so I want to understand that a
little bit better but at the same time
in parallel there's a lot of extrinsic
motivation because it was this
Groundswell thing we're slowly more and
more people you know in Australia and
across the world we're starting to tune
in yeah pay attention to what you're
doing you have media figures in
Australia who are talking about you on
the radio like Hamish and like all these
people are like you know and and a lot
of these people are also donating money
to the to the um charity piece which I
want to get into as well
um so that's that's a lot of external
pressure at the same time so how do you
think about those two factors and you
know when you wake up in the morning and
you're staring down the barrel of
another 100K and yeah you just feel like
you can't even move I guess
um
like the Instagram and the the media and
the talk is cool and I loved it because
it allowed the
um awareness of what I was doing but
also the money raised like that allowed
that to go get busted
um but getting a message from Amish or
getting a message from like
um adesanya the UFC fighter right you
were getting videos yeah I was getting
videos and all these cool things which
when I if I wasn't doing the Run would
have been amazing but mid-run it's like
that doesn't wake me up on day 10 or day
11 to go to whyalla and get this
injection it's like
why is it you're doing this and so when
I'm if I boil it down it's like
it has always been from that day one
running to Palm Beach and back about me
wanting to succeed at something for me
so when it comes to about like it was
even with the 50 marathons I did that
because I wanted to see what I could do
but raising the money was the byproduct
of people seeing it and so the same
thing with this run it's like you're a
23 year old who's never run before or
never really run before who's attempting
to run something of like magnitude that
very few people have done
how [__] cool is that like that is
wild yeah and so the pride that comes
out of me when I talk about it is like
yeah it's it's I'm just I'm so proud of
the fact I've been able to go oh my God
I can make a life in this I can
I continue to push myself while helping
people to know they're more capable of a
lot more because I haven't come from a
running background or a you know
anything like that it's all just come
from [__] let's just see what I can do
and so yeah when it's when it gets to
that point it's just like yeah
the experience of of you know being so
deep in that pain cave uh where you you
can't hide from yourself and the demons
are coming out and they're they're
talking a big game into your head and
telling you to quit and you're having
this out of body experience I mean it
really is a spiritual Odyssey 100 uh
that that you know really shows you
exactly who you are okay so so what what
did you take from that like what did you
learn from the experience of of just
being in that other place that very few
people flirt with I think that like
because you
you're not doing it all the time right
but when you are doing it it's like
like you you would know with all your
all your runs you've done
there is nothing like that
feeling of getting up and going again so
I think it's like the the pressure of
people saying you can't for one for me
but also the
what if you just take another step and
so when you do take another step what is
that going to bring what new thing are
you going to see what new feeling you're
going to feel and so like I can't there
is no words I've found yet to explain
the feeling of getting to Bondi and
seeing that because that was a
culmination of not just 47 days but
three years of or two years of busting
my ass every day making number four
o'clock
having cold showers every day it's
strict food doing like you know it's not
just like I didn't wake up one day and
go bang it was like I'm doing hard
things every day so when it does get
there it's like it was all worth it you
know what I mean I get to Bondi and see
that it's like
holy [__] and that out of body spiritual
feeling I got when I got to Bondi like a
Finish Line feel
through getting through something that
was so hard and you know everyone would
have said you couldn't have done it
uh-huh
but knowing I went through all that with
my injuries and through all that with
you know
when you look up on the highway in the
middle of this country and you can't see
anything but the Horizon of nothing
it's like
oh we're out here we're out here alone
even though I had my family and my crew
with me
I was so alone like I was so vulnerable
out there yeah and yeah to get to Bondi
and feel that like I want to get the
words to describe that but I don't think
I will for a while
but it must
give you this profound sense of of
purpose like a sense of like
I made the right choice there was
something deep inside me that guided me
to do this for a reason Beyond Myself
because in many ways like you've run
yourself into an entirely new life
actually ran from being relatively
unknown to then like
this person that people like oh [__]
what's Brockman gonna do again what's
his what's his next thing what's like
yeah and but like I like like purpose is
cool I really like I think we all have a
purpose I think there's purpose for
everyone but it's like
there's purpose in everything it's just
as long as you do it
fully like I
like for me this has all come about so
quickly so I'm not sure there might be
purpose in me doing something else in
two years like my purpose might not be
running across continents it might be
to motivate people or to you know I'm
not sure what it is but it's like as
long as I'm going
giving every giving it everything it's
that's what it is for me yeah yeah not
like not just sitting back going oh
that's cool that'd be nice it's like no
I'm whatever it is I'm deciding to do
I'm [__] doing it yeah yeah I think
that's pretty healthy I mean I think I I
see two different kinds of people who
who uh you know do these hard type of
things on the one hand there's people
that
um continue to do it like they're just
you know in a healthy way like they're
testing themselves and they're always
trying to find that outer edge in an
unhealthy way
um it's almost like they're stuck like
my value or my identity is so wed to
doing hard things if I stop doing that
then um who am I yeah you know what I
mean that's what I'm talking I think a
lot of people get caught in that trap
and it's like I have to plan the next
thing yeah you know if I don't then you
know what are people going to think of
me of course and then the other group of
people who are like I did this thing
it's changed my perspective on
capability potential who I am Etc yeah
what do I do with what I learned to
continue to grow and sometimes that
means yeah I'll do another hard thing
but sometimes it means I need to apply
this in other areas absolutely you know
absolutely I think that's the healthier
plan and it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't go and do more stuff like this
of course but to not get caught in that
trap and feel like you're doing it
because you have to feel you have to or
that you need to be in a rush to do yeah
and I think that's like I get asked that
a lot now he's like what's next what's
next and I go
I don't know yet but when I do do what
I'm going to do it's not going to be for
anyone else but me in terms of I'm not
doing it for external pressure of doing
it I'm doing it for the fact that I want
to do it because I know that spiritual
feeling I got when I finished that run I
know of that
the amount of people I had inspired and
motivated to go and like the messages I
get like you were saying it's like some
are like oh you you know you should go
see what this person's doing now Ned but
a lot of them are like
mate I know you've probably got all
these messages but I just wanted to say
I was
I was addicted to
math or I was this is literally like
I've had five or so messages like that
now I'm running I would love to run with
you well this I'm like the power of
being you and doing you you know what I
mean like if you're trying to be someone
else like people would have seen through
what I would what I did if I was trying
to be someone else yeah but because I
was being me and I was being so true to
what I want to do
that's why people were so excited about
it yeah there was no like
the [__] he's doing this for fame or
he's doing this for to be saying it's
like no I'm doing these are very attuned
to that too any sniff of that yeah and
you're you're out yeah right yeah and
it's like don't get too big on yourself
dude turn on you quick absolutely it's
like the Aussies love the underdog yeah
yeah and so but it's even now I mean now
you're not the underdog anymore no I
know I know
I feel like when I
so bad some people aren't gonna like it
but that's that's all part of it too
like you don't want I'm not I'm not
doing my days hoping that Everyone likes
me I'm doing it because I want to be me
and do me and so whatever comes of that
comes up yeah
um there's an adage in in the ultra
world that you should never uh
uh compile a crew of your friends and
loved ones because those dark moments oh
yeah back on those people uh and you
defied that rule your crew is comprised
of your girlfriend and your parents the
people you love the most
um and and you had a little bit of a
learning curve with that too right yes I
am
yeah I it's probably grown my
relationship with my girlfriend
um and my mother uh I yeah I just
finished got back from the injections
and
we're seeing that Horizon of nothing and
there's nothing in front of us
and I was just in a really foul mood I
was obviously in a lot of pain I was
still in this pain from the shin it
hadn't got easier yet and I just was
just foul I was foul yeah
um you know I'm plus thousand K in and I
just snarled at my girlfriend and I
think I told her to [__] off
um
and she was I think she was just like
I'm scared like this is not because I
was I was in a doctor I had to I had to
go to that place and I don't really know
when I'm gonna go there but when it's
[__] up out there you've just got to
find whatever it is you need to use as
fuel
um and so I just did it I just when it
went up my girlfriend I wanted to turn
on me to be honest I wanted her to go
you know you can't do it or you eat
something you know what I mean any fuel
any fuel give me fuel and so instead of
appreciating that they're there for me
to help me and use that out on the you
know use that give me fuel on the
roadkill or the road trains I used it on
my
family and my girlfriend and my you know
photographer
and so when I got to the van and my
girlfriend had spoken to my mum mum got
out of the car and just like the
mother's look of
oh like looking through everything and I
was like oh no she goes don't ever I can
talk to your girlfriend like that again
don't ever speak to like to that don't
ever speak to us like that again
um or we're all gone and I was like
noted I'm really sorry I needed that I
needed to slap in the face because I
wouldn't have seen it otherwise I if if
they kept going on and kept allowing me
to do it I would have kept pushing the
boundaries yeah
um and Mum just yeah I went and I think
she I think I've spoken to mum since and
she said I was so worried everyone would
leave and there would be you me and your
dad
that's why I had to turn on you just at
that point and I was like oh so mum was
like managing all these little
relationships because yeah I've never
been so intensely with my girlfriend
like that never been so intensive with a
photographer like that on my physio so
my mother has my mother's been with me
so she was just managing these little
fires that I was or they were starting
and so she was just like we cannot have
Gemma leave we cannot have Brad leave
yeah so she's like
Ned you know we're gonna leave meaning
they will leave if you don't freaking
shut up yeah or you know appreciate what
they're here for and take it out on
something else and so from then on it
was like Smooth Sailing but I'm sure
they would have
yeah I mean crew Rebellion is a real
thing and if you don't have that
cohesion these people are taking you
know 47 days out of their life to devote
it completely to you and to know that
you being this kind of affable fun guy
can be that dark is its own teacher
absolutely you have that inside you and
you're putting this up on your video but
that's that's why I was putting up the
terrible stuff too like I'm like I'm not
just all it's not all sunshine and
rainbows it's actually
it's hard and and my family and my
friends got that yeah
um talk about the roadkill that's real
right like I didn't realize that that is
so intense yeah there's so much of it
and the stench is just with you like the
whole time yeah it's future especially
when you got when you're eating so much
food all day and then you get that
waft probably a minute before you see
the animal
um but yeah because Australia is so with
so many so much Wildlife yeah um
kangaroos are running you're trying to
eat the food along the side of the road
and so you know in the headlights come
along they decide to run in front of the
vehicle not run away
um and yeah there's just literally
there'd be a kangaroo or a possum or a
wombat or a fox or anything just on the
road there's even a dead camel yeah they
reek the most uh but yeah it was just
like it just stuck with you and then you
can't you don't want to eat and you're
you know gagging at the thought of what
you've just run past you're trying to
hold your breath you don't want to hold
your breath because it's it stands with
you yeah so if you smell it now does it
bring you back that sense of memory
bring it right back road Trends are the
worst yeah they bring me back to the to
the road wow yeah
um I just I kind of got used to the road
kill also here's one
run past and then get on with it but
yeah sometimes you you missed them and
they were just pop up when you're right
next but
um in the in the questions that like
wardian and hella and Robbie uh uh
shared with me for you
um there were a couple I mean wardian I
think Robbie also asked wanted to know
like what was the most unreal act of
kindness that you experienced because I
think these guys they're running across
America so they're going through towns
all the time they're interacting with
lots of people
um plenty of you know opportunities to
like have chats and stuff like that but
I don't know that that would have been
an experience that you would have had
right because there's so few well you're
in these Road houses you are seeing some
people along the way right yeah I I was
I was saying a lot of truckies so the
truckies were starting to recognize me
and when I would get to halfway across
here he's still going how far is he run
where's he going to yeah
um there was a few like really cool
times where I like when I got to Mildura
which was like the first big kind of
town since you know Perth
um the whole town was lining up and I
was like if this is what Mildura is like
and Wagga was pretty well the same
what's
Sydney gonna be like like this is this
is wild yeah
um and honking and cash donations and I
think someone um rocked up and gave 1500
cash just on the side of a freaking
Highway this is like nullapool area
um I guess like majority of people were
so like had heard about it by the time I
got halfway through so there was always
like every second car was a honk or
um filming or standing up donating and
there was no real
um I'm trying to think about standout
um
yeah I can't really what about uh you
have any run-ins with the cops yeah on
day two
um so because I initially in the
planning with the legal like the state
and governments they said I had to run
at sunrise and sunset
I couldn't run anytime either side of it
and
um
yeah I well obviously
I'm running yeah um and I got to
the end of day two in the local copper
has had clocked me at like 60k and he'd
pull it up you gotta get off this road
I've had my one of my best mates was
killed I'm walking along here so I need
you just I think it was his own thing I
was like yep no worries but like I'm
about to go into
30 or 40 plus more days of this yeah
like I appreciate that but I've got to
get going that feels so far away I'm
only just picturing that again like day
two
felt so much longer away than what day
46 was like that feels like six years
ago that moment but Bondi feels like a
week ago yeah where time's weird that
way right especially schedules probably
feel a lot longer and then time starts
to like morph where the later days yeah
you're starting to feel good again but
you're in this trance and this
um Flow State for so long you just wake
up and when you do get into it it's okay
and then and then you're at 80k and
you're like okay I remember this
Roadhouse remember that where I left but
you don't really remember the
in-betweens
and I think that might be a bit of PTSD
but and you had airpods in in all the
photos so what were you listening to
were you listening to music what do you
what are you pumping into the head
um I was first 10 days finally I didn't
listen to anything that was all mute no
music uh and then by about day 20 I was
at 4 30 in the morning AC DC blasting
yeah because I just was like I was using
it um kind of the way Goggins talks
about it as cheating
um
how you like we've put music in it it
makes it easier yeah so I was using it
like the last 10k of a few days last 10K
but it's like torture when you aren't
using it when you know it's there and
because it wasn't hard enough you had to
make it harder yeah exactly exactly
um but I as modern podcast when I could
um when I was like you know fine for me
to listen and um not actually be in pain
so to speak I could listen to it but
when I was hurting and when which was
majority of the time I was just playing
yeah yeah
um Ravi wanted to know if you had any
kind of mantras or or mindset tricks
that allowed you to kind of weather the
the dark moments I just it was always
the just if you can't run just walk just
go and walk to the next pose so there's
obviously the signposts along the way
and I'd be like if today's a day where
i'm not really feeling it I would run to
a post walk to a post run to a post walk
to a post until I got into the rhythm of
like okay this runs good but it would be
like at the end of each day I wrote my
Instagram uh poster
which was almost like a reflection for
me it was like this beautiful
um
amount of time for me to sit back do my
diary Journal but on Instagram and I at
the end of each one I was just like
telling myself I've got to just find a
way like find a way find a way and that
would be why I got through the shin and
why we got you know it's just like
do not give in just find a way of what
you've got to do yeah and so I think it
I think find a way was a good Mantra I
had
um and then just keep showing up so it's
a similar thing yeah talk to me about
the mullet
yeah did you have a mullet beforehand
yeah yeah you did how long have you been
a rock in the mullet I've been in and
out of them for probably since year six
but in between job interviews I had to
cut them and go again
um I think I think the main reason for
it is like the breaking down of
like a stereotype so when I walk into a
room you already have a idea of me if
you don't know who I am
and if I go in there and I can hold a
conversation I've also raised two and a
half million dollars for a charity and I
can run you know you've you've already
got this preconceived idea of me being
some buffet tradie that you know goes
out all weekend but you know you can
also not and it's like if I walk in a
room with you know people in suits or
whatever and I'd Rock up like this
breaks down barriers straight away and
it's like this you know I can it's just
like tattoos or it's like I this is me
you know yeah and there's no like I
don't have to be clean cutting
to be a good person or to be a a good
man like it's it's just me uh-huh yeah
and I like I think I like doubling down
on it as well but now it's iconic
absolutely yeah you can no there's no
way right and it like it it it precedes
you every room you walk into yeah right
now that you're like this media darling
like highly you're recognizable at like
200 meters yeah way more recognizable
from the back than the first yeah yeah
absolutely how does that
um
how has that been like now you know
three months later
uh you know you go from this just you
know kind of normal bloke into into
being somebody who you know is is
probably recognized everywhere you go
especially in Sydney especially in
Sydney especially around the beaches
yeah
um
even Byron like I went up here yesterday
I'm going oh it's gonna be nice that's
peaceful I'm gonna walk around Main
Street get some food to eat just chill
out
and I'm like getting every third man's
going man
it's too hot though
um yeah it's been it's been fine and I
was saying before it's like
I can't raise money can't
um you know be this person to use
inspiration without being known so now I
am it's like you take the good with the
bad
um like you know sometimes walking down
to woolies and getting your food you
don't want to be pulled over and say can
I get a photo but
it's all part of it and it's like that
might be there one time to meet me and
so I don't want to be seeing offers
being a blog or I want to be myself but
I've also got to appreciate that I don't
want you know I've got a be by myself
and with myself a lot too sure can't
always give my energy but but there's
got to be a lot of gratitude with that
too they're not they're not doing that
because they saw you in a reality show
Absolutely they're recognizing you for
the you know the Valor of the
accomplishments and people felt felt
like they were on their Journey with me
yeah they're your friends yeah
absolutely and I'm somewhat approachable
on my Instagram so I think people they
already know you my life absolutely hey
mate how's that this oh that's right
social media yeah the power yeah so no
it's been cool it's been a weird
transition and it's like I'm just I'm
starting to find peace in it as well
knowing that you know people are just
going to know me the more and more I
deal with this the more and more people
are going to know me
um just go with it I feel like most
people wanna eat better they want to
improve their diets absolutely have you
heard of it I've heard of it this trips
up so many people we thought hey we know
a couple things about how to do this a
few so we created this thing called the
plant power meal planner that is this
beautiful offering whereby you gain
access to literally thousands of
plant-based recipes that you can totally
customize based upon your preferences
your allergies your peccadillos it
integrates with grocery delivery so all
the ingredients that you need get
shipped right to your door so you can
make the stuff that you've pre-selected
and we all could use a little
inspiration and support when preparing
meals for our families in our busy lives
so we hope you join us no matter what
your eating style is we have our arms
open wide and we've saved you a space at
our family table to join us in eating
more healthy vibrant plant-based meals
visit meals Dot richroll.com
[Laughter]
all right so talk to me about
um the homelessness issue why you
decided that this was going to be
the cause that you wanted to direct your
attention towards and and Leverage The
Run to raise funds to combat yeah I get
on on the homelessness I think a lot of
people would be confused with me doing
the whole run for homelessness and I do
want to clear that up that it's like I
wanted to do it for
see what I could possibly see what's
possible what I'm capable of to help
Inspire and then to also help on the
side the homelessness came about when I
moved to Sydney from the country and I
saw a heap of homeless people in Eddie
Avenue which is in the city when I went
to um I would ride or run or walk into
Tafe
and I was like just
confronted by how much homelessness
there was and so initially I'm like [__]
how do I how do I talk to these people
like I don't know how you know
approaching them how to approach them
how to you know interact where I'm like
now I'm like it's so [__] stupid
because they're just people who need
help so my initial you know hesitation
was
obviously I think what a lot of people
feel they don't know how to go up and
help
um I just called my mom said what do I
do and she goes just talk to the mate
get down to their level and just talk to
them right yeah that's right so I would
go up and I'd go hey how you going I'm
Ned get to the eye level introduce
myself make and feel as comfortable as
possible
um and just to be like can I get your
food can I get water can I get you
anything
um and a lot of times they're just like
uh I don't want your help so just they
didn't acknowledge didn't acknowledge me
at all but a lot of times they would
they go oh thank you I'd love that this
would be great and it just was like
every time I left I had this profound
feeling of like like it just I needed to
help I needed to every time I walked
past someone
I'd needed to help them and so
I was like [__] my running starting to
get a bit wild my 50 marathons I just
said I'm like I'm gonna do some
homelessness so I raised 100 Grand when
I did the 50 and 50.
um and then yeah it kind of just went I
wanna I wanna do something with this run
I want to keep in theme of the
homelessness as well and let's raise a
million dollars and yeah it kind of just
came about that way and how did you
decide upon the non-profit that would
deploy those funds in the best way yeah
so Noah who owns mobilize and we are
mobilize which is the charity I raised
for he reached out to me during the 50
marathons in 50 days and was like what
you're doing is incredible we're a
homeless charity homelessness charity
then all volunteers uh the most That
Ever Raised prior to this run was 15
grand in a year
um and they literally a lot of them were
just literally getting money out of
their own pockets and buying stuff and
going and starting conversation but
their bread and butter is conversation
so going up and starting talking with
these people and seeing where the help
can be given uh so it was quite cool
that it was the way I went and started
talking to people on the street
um and yeah then I went oh that's right
no I reached out and they did really
cool stuff hey mate do you want me to
we're gonna raise a million dollars for
you you can he's like yeah
um and then yeah fast forward to now we
raised 2.5 million yeah you got two and
a half yeah what's interesting is that
that when you started I mean you didn't
even have 100K raised right when the Run
started no so it just picked up steam
along the way yeah dude um I think I hit
a hundred thousand dollars on like day
six and then I was about 450
000 with 10 days to go and then I was
1.7 million when I hit Bondi right I
think people especially Australians
want to say the person finished before
they give their cash I mean honestly
it's it's it is this is what happened
with the 50 and 50. I think I had 20 000
raised with 10 days to go then I raised
a hundred thousand um but they just love
it when you and they want to say and
help because a lot of the donation was
to help for homelessness but a lot was
to
thank me for what I've done for them
yeah and so that's what like Mark Boris
said that to you like he donated he's
like yeah I know it's for this but I'm
really doing it for you yeah yeah and
for what you've done for me
um and that was that was cool but I
think that's what a lot of the later
influx was for so this motherfucker's
done it guys yeah yeah
um homelessness is such a such an
intractable problem you know it entails
socioeconomic conditions systemic issues
political issues mental health addiction
all of that like it's a Sticky Wicket
right like you can buy somebody a meal
or you know maybe you know give them a
helping hand but solving the problem
itself is you know I I mean I don't know
the nature of the problem here in
Australia but it's it's in the United
States yeah it's massive in the states
um I think the
misconception is that it's addiction
it's alcoholism it's
um
it's actually like here in Australia
it's housing affordability
um domestic violence and like a few
other things that have just like not
having a family that's there for you and
something goes wrong you know a lot of
people are one paid check away from
being on the street
um and so like with mobilize now their
their bread and butter obviously is the
interaction and conversation for change
but they're now implementing another
pillar which is
um
they go out and they for example they
have because they have this so much
funding
they're gonna actually help so say
you're homeless you need health care or
you need
um you know you need a place to rent you
need to gather together 10 grand
I've I'm from mobilize I go up to you
and say you know what is it you need
they go I need 10 grand for this if you
can raise five grand we'll give you the
other five so you can show and we can
help you and see where you can save it
we can do this so actually helping allow
them to get into right somewhere instead
of giving them a fair shot so you know
here's teach them how to fish exactly
being like well if you're willing to
give this a go and we'll give you all
the tools to help
we will help fund half or you know
whatever it is
um to help make that happen and so but
it doesn't have to be about health care
or housing or whatever it can be
anything but as long as it's going to
Aid them in potentially
making them get off the street then
that's what we're hoping yeah sorry go
ahead homeless like
whether we like it or not everyone has
needs so
money is like you know me saying I gave
them food or water it's like I'm having
a preconceived idea of what they can do
with money so instead of being you know
like going we need to give you food a
water because that's what I think you
need so where they have needs the money
is Theirs to do if you're going to give
them something and they want the money
and you're willing to give something
you know what I mean like that
hard we we all have needs sure sure and
and is the the fundraising still open it
is still open and then you can still
obviously donate to mobilize and they
are incredible like the this one
volunteer he's my he's 26 he started it
uh just all young volunteers who I was
on a done a few Zoom calls with them and
they're just the most passionate helpful
people I'm like this is great like this
is what you're doing the real work yeah
and like just they're all volunteers
there's no one
doing anything and I would hope that
Noah who started it would be able to
pay himself a bit of a wage to start
going full time in it because of how
passionate it is about it but he won't
he just won't do it well so anyway don't
work it out right so it's we are
immobilized with an S right in America
that uses these but yeah at our.com yeah
um what is it that that
you want people to you know take away
from this experience that you've had in
terms of how they reflect upon
themselves
I think
um knowing
limit your limitations so I think a lot
of people sit back and go
there's no
there's no way I could do that no way I
could do what they've done so it's like
allow yourself to think and you know
there doesn't have to be ambitious
people like people love just happy with
their day right and happy with getting
on with whatever it is but I think if
you're hesitating
in wanting to do something but I don't
know how it's like
don't overthink it just go for it you're
not gonna No One's Gonna Rouse on you
for having a go No One's Gonna you know
what I mean you're not gonna let anyone
down by having a crack at something I
think it's showing people and giving
people that hope that they can also
whatever it is they want to do go and do
it so
you're now in a situation where you're
going to be getting up on stages and and
and doing Keynotes and kind of
delivering this type of message
including an event I know you're going
to be at an event where Goggins is also
speaking which is very exciting for you
that's great it is especially on your
face yeah it's your very first one yeah
I've done it like the Q a uh yeah it's a
different thing very different yeah so
you're working it out uh yes getting
there yeah I finally got uh two weeks
but I've got I've got a pretty good plan
that's good man so are you are you still
doing the electrician thing or is that
no no more being
I just
again it's like for me when I moved to
Sydney it was exciting and you know I'm
doing like being electrician and I'll be
able to you know even if it was
electrical that I ended up doing it
would be I would have 100 guys working
for me or I would I mean I'd be just
pushing pushing and pushing
um but now it's not it's it's this Ultra
scene and it's this motivation and it's
inspiration and
um in five years time might be something
different but hopefully I've now
uh got somewhat of a name to be able to
then use that to continue to live and be
right able to do this yeah you're so
young man yeah you got your whole life
ahead of you to figure this out yeah and
you're in a position now where yeah you
have girlfriend and stuff like that but
you don't have a ton of liabilities and
responsibilities and you have the
flexibility to kind of pivot and move
and and you know it's very exciting of
your dreams it's it's cool man yeah and
um yeah I'm just I'm just pumped to be
able to you know I I have actually
created this yeah so now it's like where
to now yeah so speaking
what else for the moment
um yeah I'll be on the on the speaking
circuit and just like
back into training back into like
getting fit and healthy and happy and
being like excited about training
um and then yeah working on probably
another event I um just because I want
to do it I'm I'm stinging from that what
I've just been through so yeah I'm just
um
just trying not nothing set in stone
there's no like you know there's still
there's a few ideas I've got circulating
but
um yeah nothing yet but I think it'll be
just like oh we can try this so we could
do this and and maybe I'll get a lot
more sponsors together or whatever and
yeah and make it even even cooler
what is the uh
uh what was the nutrition strategy when
you were doing the run like I know it
gets difficult to keep food down and all
of that but knowing you're you know you
got to get I don't know some ungodly
amount of calories in you every single
day yeah so I the plan was 10 000 cows a
day but
it's quite hard to do when you're moving
so much and the lack of food along the
way so we had to store everything or you
know what we could purchase wasn't great
um I was every so in the morning would
be oats
um heap of brown sugar on it and then a
coffee banana strawberries
um and then I would usually vomit that
up by about an hour in
um and then because they're just like
the phlegm I had from the dirt and yeah
mosquitoes and the you know it was just
it's pretty wild
and then I would probably try and eat
every hour on the hour 500 cows if I
could
but I was never really getting that in I
ended up losing about 12 kilos over the
whole run so I mean I plateaued at about
70 kilos and I was probably eating and
burning the same amount by then but all
the way up I was burning way more and
eating heaps less yeah um but I came
into it quite heavy like with extra
weight sorry
um so I had that to lose but it's not 12
kilos but I had probably six or so to
lose where I'm at my probably Peak
weight uh and then yeah obviously I
probably lost a few more kilos than I
would have liked but that put that back
on no worries yeah when uh when you were
coming into Bondi that final day yeah is
it true that your final Marathon was a
oh no so that was in the 50 marathons in
50 days I mean okay okay yes I misread
that or I misread that on my 50th
marathon of the in 2020 was a um yeah
253 yeah that's after doing it right
um but I was I ran 60k on the last day
um from Campbelltown into Bondi but even
then like uh we woke up at like 7 30.
I started 60 cat around that day I felt
like I'd finished but I still had to run
60 kilometers where it's like because
that's the way it works right you're
like oh it's just 60 kilometers and I'm
done like I'm basically finished with
this whole thing yeah and then I'm like
oh [__] 60 cows a long way isn't it and
like I was running through towns with no
like Road paths like um true suburbs
with no paths that no one ever runs out
there
um and so I'm like this is [__] up
like I've just run on this highway the
whole way and now I've been trying to
navigate streets and work out where I'm
going but yeah it was it was pretty nice
when I went to bonda I got to Bondi
about 20 minutes early because I told
everyone 5 30 I got there at five
o'clock and um it's like
cop Convoy like people storming
helicopters above me and I'm like oh no
did you have a sense that that would be
waiting for you or was that a total
shocker total shop yeah I I knew it was
going to be like I knew there'd be a few
people there like
a thousand or two maybe uh-huh
but even that's a lot
um
and I just like I remember running in
halfway up the road before Bondi Road
and I just saw two helicopters and I'm
like what's that but they were like
hovering with me
this is for me
um yeah and then I just I remember
coming down so I'm running down Bono
Bono Road
um
from the south end
and just every person was like and you
know when there's this like this
hysteria of like you they don't know
what's going on but they know
something's going on so there was like
half the people knew what was going on
but the rest were like what's all this
commotion about and um by so this is me
in this left lane in the Bondi road
which never gets shut uh they've blocked
it off for me
I'm running down and I just saw the
beach like the Promenade and it was like
uh
a summer's day in Bondo on steroids yeah
like you don't see it like that yeah
um and then I I got quite taken back I
got quite like
almost like
tall poppy syndrome like you don't
deserve this sort of like
and then and then about 10 seconds later
I went you've been through hell and back
Matt you just [__] you are yeah and
then there's just like I'm just like
screaming at everyone like yeah it was
pretty cool it was crazy I mean people
who are watching or listening go to
Ned's Instagram and you got the videos
there yeah and stuff I mean they're I
don't know how many thousands of people
were there but yeah plenty yeah I'm not
I don't really know and I the the number
changes every time I say it so I'd say
around 10 000 to be honest yeah maybe
more I'm not really sure but then you go
like the wide shot from the Drone it's
like the whole Beach and then the whole
like it's wild yeah
um one of the one of the uh injuries
that you used to stand that I gotta hear
more about is uh the fact that you had
like maggots burrowing in your toe yeah
so is that due to like blisters and
swelling or whatever and then it's the
flies like laying eggs yeah yep it's
pretty well it so when you you know your
toenails peel off right
um it would my big right toenail had
like
a half come off so it was like an
opening but it wasn't fully out so I
didn't like try to pull it off and
we were just cruising along finished a
run a lot of flies in the outback of
Australia
um and had flown in and I'm obviously
like kicking him away and
and then
two days later or three days later I'm
in the nullable Roadhouse like the most
remote Roadhouse of Australia and I'm my
toes like aching it felt like an ingrown
toenail and I'm like I'm trying to pull
this skin away and I'm like this is [__]
keeping me up like it's full-on I could
not sleep because of it I couldn't
really sleep anyway but um that was just
like a whole other thing so I've clipped
my nail half my nail off and still
wouldn't still didn't fix it so I've got
out the run and 40K into the run it's
raining pissing down rain and I thought
it must be water in my toe so I've
pulled my socks off
and there's no like like I've dried it
and it's like all good
and I'm like [__] maybe we need to dry
it out get some alcohol spray so it
sprayed some alcohol into it
and then maggots just sat crawling out
of it yeah and so I'm like oh no because
I obviously want to get out of the
alcohol so they've just dispersed I'm
like
I've got maggots in my time because I
saw this like red this red blood thing
move sliding away and it was a freaking
it was like five maggots in there
so then we got the cotton Bud scraped it
out and then um yeah put the new sock on
freaked out a bit worked out like try to
check it out yeah we've got a video you
haven't shared that one I haven't shared
it I think we're gonna try and use a new
doctor oh you're making a documentary um
potentially yeah because we've got one
favorite a footage
um so we'll see yeah we'll see about I
just yeah it just depends on like the
work to put into it and reverse outcome
so but your PT said that possibly the
fact that you had maggots in your toe
kept it from getting infected yeah it
was actually a blessing absolutely and I
think that you just [__] up to think
about yeah well it is if you had to
clean a wound yeah
obviously the big ones but like the
smaller and they just eat away at the
infection and take them out which is
[__] like it is so gross I am yeah I
did question my life choice at that
point uh but we scraped them out and
we're good to go and I didn't have any
pain after that which is great yeah
um
so so life after the run you went to the
the GQ Man of the Year Awards a lot of
people are calling for you to be
Australian of the year 2023. yeah that's
a bit of a head [__] it is a head [__]
especially when
you know when I was out there
on the road like I'm not thinking any of
this I'm thinking about getting
back to bond night and like you know
some people being there so when you know
I do get invited to those things or
I feel weird going out there and
accepting an award because I'm like
but I guess all the people in there were
just the same at some point not
necessarily the Running part but you
know had a dream of being a singer or a
dream being an actor and then finally an
actor and then they're up there
accepting their award for their solo
actor you know and so or best solo
artist uh and when I went up there I'm
like
it's hard to believe I'm happy to be
perfectly honest like being in you know
two weeks into the run on the nullar
ball having no clue what was ahead of me
to being here dressed up in a suit that
I do not feel comfortable in
um is very like it's very surreal and
like you know I've got the prime
minister in front of me yeah Russell
Crowe uh you know all these people and
I'm like I'm swearing my head off and
I'm like oh well it's just me isn't it
so no it's very cool and it's been yeah
I did pinch myself but I know I've got
so much more to give and I know I've got
so much more
in me that people want to say and that I
want to give to people yeah so it's like
embrace it
the uh the fact that it's GQ and you're
rocking the mullet like that there's
just something really beautiful I love
that yeah but no but it's powerful yeah
you're gonna bring it back absolutely
are there a bunch of like you know Ned
acolytes cruising around now with bleach
blonde mullets I get um there's always
like
you know the sports parties or people
have parties and it's like rock up as
your favorite athlete or your favorite
for Halloween people dress up like you
you're out of freaking things I got
tagged into that was great but there's a
few there's a few play tomorrow together
yeah my favorite of the things that
you've done though didn't you did you do
a thing with the uh uh the inspired
unemployed uh the a podcast oh yeah
those guys like those I love the like I
don't know I can't remember when I tuned
into those guys but I love those guys
yeah they're so like they're so
they're so funny those dudes so they're
they're such good boys like they're so
they're just like you're every day dude
but they've just done some funny content
yeah and it's just blown up people love
it you know just like like they've you
know they've got some anxieties and
they've got they're just they're just
the everyday dudes you know what I mean
they're just doing their thing and
they're
um like they presented the award at the
GQ for me um and that was so nervous
before it and it's like you know what I
mean it's like this stuff is you have to
be trained to you know you have to do
stuff like this to be good at it but you
know you're doing like for me like going
up there I'm like this is [__] wild
but now you know the more care notes I
do the more you know this sort of stuff
I do the more comfortable we are talking
about your story
um but yeah those those boys are so good
they're so funny and they've done so
well out of it
on the keynote thing you know if you're
just yourself and you just you know like
double down on on just the authenticity
of who you are and and keep it real all
the rest of it takes care of itself yeah
true you know and you've done a few yeah
I'm not great at it it's not like my I
can do it and I've done plenty of them I
don't think it's my strength yeah um
I've learned a lot doing it though but I
think the the ones that I've done that
have been the best are where like I know
what I I know like the things that I
want to say but I just I don't try to
like be so tied to that and I just kind
of like show up and be present yeah and
and relaxed then it's better that's more
important than like staying on script
and then I think just making it about
the audience like of course not it's not
about you but like how like okay who are
these people like where do they come
from yeah what are they interested in
hearing about and the more you can like
customize it because once you make it
about them because once you have the
script it's like you know well then it
starts to just become I mean I did it so
many times after a while I was like is
this even true like I I just yeah I felt
so disconnected from what I was saying
that I was like I don't want to do this
anymore or you know if I'm going to do
it I have to just throw that out and
Yeah like show up blank slaves talk yeah
so I don't know but I'm excited for you
man yeah it's exciting it's gonna be and
I know you know the first One's Gonna
potentially suck and that's all part of
it I've done a few already like on my
own not in front of anyone or like in
front of my girlfriend but I um
yeah it's gonna be like you know you're
rehearsing because the power the slides
and everything yeah I have to yeah I
need pointers to remember whatever are
you uh are you have any plans to come to
the states
um in April hopefully oh yeah yeah
um potentially speak with like a sponsor
like a global sponsor um and do you know
cam Hanes yes yes yeah hunting and I
know that he he likes all your posts I
saw that um and I was like oh that's
cool cam I've never met him but we've
communicated a little bit on the
internet and uh super like you know it
really it like you know has a positive
attitude about everything you know just
supporting as many people yes yeah yes
and he's just like no [__] and like
yeah I think it's great I think we need
people like that you know yeah so you're
gonna go hang out with him I'm gonna go
and try and pull a bow and
um yeah that's a video I want to see
yeah yeah yeah bow hunting in Oregon
with with Cam Hanes and go for a run
nice man yeah well I'm sure there's
plenty of uh eager hosts for you in the
states yeah I think that'd be good
um just as a final thing to kind of uh
you know close this thing down I already
asked you a little bit about like what
you want people to take away from from
your run but I think uh you know there's
a lot of people uh
you know to your point uh who gets stuck
in their head or walk around with a a
sense of incapacity about their own
possibility and and potential you uh you
know you serve as this really you know
kind of shining star in terms of you
know what we're all capable of because
in so many ways you are like the every
man and you just discovered running a
couple years ago you're so young
um but you know speak to that person who
who does feel kind of stuck on the couch
or every time they feel like they take a
stab at something it snaps back on them
and and and they're just you know
feeling a little bit directionless I
think making sure
that you're you're not doing it
because you feel you should do it
because
it's like the right thing to do so when
like you as you said before it's like as
you see through the [__] of people
trying to do it for something other than
them wanting to do it for them so when
if you're doing it for you know you per
someone to like you or you know someone
to compliment you on something or you
know whatever it is in that way it's
like that that will not be enough to get
you can to continually keep getting up
off that couch and so
do it for
for you to feel good or for you to
succeed in something that you've always
felt you know man so
yeah I guess like not not doing it for
any other reason then
for the the reason that you want to do
it if that makes sense not like not for
any external validation yeah
um
yeah I I I'm and I wish I want a bit
more time to probably word that but that
I guess that's the essence of one yeah I
mean when I when I reflect upon uh you
know how how you've accomplished this
thing I mean it really it feels to me
like it you know it started with with
one little jog because you you had the
back fat and you didn't like it
literally it wasn't it it wasn't like
some Grand ambition that you were going
to run across Australia it was one tiny
step and yeah you know when I asked you
about mantras and you're talking about
just getting to the next Lamppost it's
breaking everything down into really
easily you know repeatable digestible
actions and and you know the levers
really moved through those tiny things
undertaken every day anonymously years
to bloke at home going out for a jog
here and there and you strung some
things together that led to something
fantastic that's actually it didn't
begin that way so I think like being
humble and and just getting into the
habit of of kind of flexing the muscle
of self-care wherever that kind of
instinct or or inspiration is is leading
you is really the the kind of impulse to
pay attention to absolutely and like
like how many New Year's resolutions are
like a two-weight setup you've changed
everything dramatically and then they're
back into doing the amount and so I
think it's like you know I didn't start
with I didn't start with running
100K I didn't start with ice cold baths
every day or ice showers every day cold
showers every day I didn't start with
reading Tomatoes the book I started with
go for a run okay I'm getting further in
my running now I can incorporate eating
well all the setting was actually really
helping me and it was just like this
incremental increase in
doing the more uncomfortable things so
when that became comfortable I just did
the next thing and then all of a sudden
I'm you know beating down marathons and
I'm running further and I'm you know
I've got this energy about me that I'm
running around being like hello how are
you happy freaking Friday how was this
how Goods living blah blah blah like it
was never like it was just this energy
coming out of me so I think it's just
these
slow steps that allow you but being
consistent and disciplined to make sure
you continue to do it and then you know
even like with the weight loss it
started out as a external you know lose
weight
but what I found when I was trying to do
that was this feeling of achievement by
getting the next run by getting the next
run and all of a sudden I'm you know
doing these long runs and I'm feeling
this excitement about how far I can push
myself so when
you know now it's got nothing to do with
losing weight the weight is a byproduct
of now me being happy and me being
content with what I'm doing yeah
beautiful man well I appreciate you
taking the time here I wanted to say I
asked you before you came out I was like
bring me a budgie Smuggler yeah so
here's this is your sponsor right in the
eye I love that like like an ultra
Runner who ran across Australia had like
basically like a a a bathing suit
company as your sponsor shout out there
is nothing more Australian than the
budgie Smuggler as you bring me one this
is like perfect and I feel like I'm an
honorary citizen of uh of Australia now
thank you um I'm proud to be I'll be
able to give you a pair equalizer oh
wear it proudly yeah absolutely
um on the surfboard today yeah
uh super inspired by your Feats by your
example and but I think more than that
and like I said at the outset like the
reason I wanted to talk to you has less
to do with the fact that you ran across
Australia and and more about like how
you comport yourself and I think in this
age of social media influencer there's
there's a lot of like not so great
influencers out there I've got four kids
and I think a lot about like who are
they looking up to yeah who are you know
the North Stars of people that they can
like draw wisdom from and the fact that
you you know being at your age uh you
know can serve that for young people and
old people like me
um I think is really cool and so I just
wanted to honor you for that and let you
know that I appreciate what you're doing
and and uh I'm I'm at your service man I
love everything about you and it's been
great to meet you thank you and you I've
been yeah it's been an honor to be here
I'm really truly am very grateful and
I'm blessed to meet you thank you cheers
uh everybody definitely check out Ned's
Instagram uh if Ned's new to you because
he he you know you're probably new to a
lot of people in the states definitely
um you can scroll through his feed and
get a pretty good sense of of not just
the adventure but like who this guy is
pretty cool Ned with two D's Brockman
with two ends Doubleday doubling yeah
there you go
yourself
um we'll put up links to we are mobilize
and your website and all that other good
stuff man so thank you cheers peace
peace
[Music]